so in this lesson we're going to talk
about similar triangles and similar
triangles are something that's covered
on the act in various forms so let's go
through it and we'll do a couple
examples so first of all
when you want to show that two triangles
are similar what exactly does that mean
well first of all what it means is that
the triangles have the same
shape but not necessarily the same size
so what that means is that the
corresponding angles are congruent but
the corresponding sides meaning the
sides that match up they're proportional
so you might remember from your geometry
class that you can show that triangles
are similar by either using the angle
angle similarity or the side side side
or the side angle side and we'll go
through that in a just in a brief uh
moment here so basically what we want to
do is we want to look at the two
triangles so say your triangles look
like this
and say for example that this angle and
this angle are congruent
and this angle and this angle are
congruent
what you can see then is that
automatically the third angles will also
be congruent and
these triangles are then going to be
similar meaning that the corresponding
sides are proportional so
this is the form that it usually comes
up in but it also can come up in this
side side side form where you have
three sides of one triangle are in the
same
ratio as three sides of another triangle
for example like this might be triple
this side and this might be triple this
side and so on
so let's go into the the first example
here now what i'd like for you to do is
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can solve this problem yourself and then
go ahead and you know check your answer
when we go through it together so first
of all
it says the triangles are similar find
the perimeter of triangle def so these
two triangles are similar but we're
trying to find the perimeter of this
triangle so go ahead and pause it see if
you can solve it and then we'll come
back and check your answer
okay so now what we want to notice is
that
see if we were to match up these
triangles you can see 3
is to 9
okay that's multiplied by 3 right 4 is
to 12 that's multiplied by 3
5 is to 15. so you can see that the
scale factor is 3 we're tripling so we
know that the side is 15 we can then add
up all three sides so this is going to
be let's see that's uh 27 plus 9 which
is how much 36. so the perimeter is just
going to be 36 units the other way that
you can do this problem is you could say
well let me find out the perimeter of
this shape this is 3 plus 4 plus 5
that's 12
and if i know the scale factor is 3 i
know i'm you know multiplying everything
by three the perimeter will also be
three times larger so we just have to
take 12 times three and that's 36. okay
now let's go to a more challenging
example example number two so it says
it's a sunny day and you notice that you
are casting a shadow that's four feet
long and you are six feet tall a nearby
tree casts a shadow that's 90 feet long
how tall is the tree so again go ahead
and pause the video see if you can solve
this problem then we'll go through it
together
okay so the first thing that i would do
on a problem like this is just draw a
picture so here's the sun over here okay
and let's just say that uh you're over
here okay
and you're casting your shadow like this
so you can see this is forming a
triangle actually a right triangle okay
and here's the angle of the sun like
this
all right and so here's the shadow it
looks like it's four feet long and
you're six feet tall
now over here we've got a tree that's a
little bit larger okay
see if i can draw a tree here for you
and it's casting a shadow that says it's
uh 90 feet long so this is 90
and we're trying to find the height of
the tree
so what you'll notice here is that the
angle of sun is going to be the same in
both of these examples so we know that
this angle and this angle are congruent
we're assuming that the tree is
perpendicular to the ground and that
you're perpendicular to the ground so
these are right angles so you can see we
just like we talked about over here the
angle angle if we know two angles are
congruent to two angles then we know
that the triangles are similar which
means that the corresponding sides are
proportional so all we have to do now is
compare the corresponding side so we
know that
your height is to the height of the tree
so six is to h
as your shadow
is to the tree's shadow so as 4 is to
90. all we have to do now is cross
multiply so 4 times h equals 6 times 90
which is 540 and then divide both sides
by 4 so that's going to be let's see 135
feet
so that's the height of the tree so
again similar triangles this is
something you definitely want to
understand it's generally involving
you know making a proportion and
comparing the corresponding size but it
could involve something like the
perimeter like this example we did here